here
yep okay great so it's here in the
classrooms where the pandemics
devastation can be felt
and education interrupted with
long-lasting damage
now to minimize disruption 12 to 15 year
olds being told they can and should take
the covid vaccine
so parents understandably have a mixture
of views it was interesting head teacher
elroy cahill tells me parents are
divided and conflicted
we certainly encourage parents to make
an informed choice
certainly from the perspective of
keeping education
going as as normal as possible i think
vaccination is certainly welcomed
we're very mindful that we've had
significant disruption over the last two
years
to young people's education and what we
want to students
in every classroom get an excellent
education every lesson every day
the children here are understandably as
divided as their parents
i can't afford to miss any time of
school because of cloven i don't think
anyone else no you can
so i feel like it would be very
it would be so much more beneficial if
our year and our age group took the
vaccine despite being vaccinated you
could still get covered so it's just a
risk i'm not willing to take
the recommendation from the uk's chief
medical officers is that children aged
between 12 and 15 can be offered a
single dose of the fisa jab their
decision comes after the jcbi reported
there would only be marginal gains in
children's health if they took the
vaccine
these two are not in conflict and what
we've done is we've added in
some wider considerations as jcboi
suggested and we're you know i don't
think in in our view certainly as chief
medical officers and uh professor lin
may want to comment as chair of jcbi we
do not see a conflict between these the
cmo says there is no division but
instead he's looked at the wider impact
of covid's disruption to school life
do you professor whitley regret
the way this is being communicated what
we would really regret and i i want to
be you know really clear about this is
getting the decision wrong in this
situation it is a more difficult one and
i think it is appropriate therefore that
people have taken longer to get to this
and to make sure we weighed all the
different elements up to get this
this right i think it was entirely
appropriate that we
offered the advice to
the secretary of state and we
communicated advice to the public so
people understood
where jcbi stood
it may now fall to people like dr
whitaker to allay parental concerns
the first new vaccine that's been
introduced that parents have had
concerns about
and our job has always been to interpret
the evidence that we have and make sure
that whoever makes a decision and it
should be a joint decision for that
young person and their parents that they
understand what the benefits are and
what the risks are both to themselves
and perhaps to their family and their
individual circumstances
the decision to vaccinate will fall to
parents and rightly their children after
all we're told it's a difficult decision
taken to safeguard their futures
ashish joshi sky news